democrat congressman corey bush decided
to mark
our nation's independence day by
decrying america as a rotten
evil illegitimate country quote
when they say that the fourth of july is
about american freedom she tweeted
remember this the freedom they're
referring to is for
white people this land is stolen land
and black people still aren't free now
ms bush did not elaborate on how an
enslaved woman
managed the liberty to tweet her inane
musings
much less get elected to congress but
unfortunately her point of view has
become
the mainstream one the nation's largest
teacher union is now
vowing to push critical race theory in
all 50 states
npr added a trigger warning to the
declaration of independence
and a new report reveals the organized
campaign
to push radical sexual ideologies into
kids programming i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from ryan brewer
who says
if football is everything and everything
is racist
doesn't that make the nfl racist i think
it does i think that's
that's pretty good argumentation don't
think the nfl is capable of that kind of
a philosophical understanding speaking
of i i have a second place i have a
runner-up for my favorite comment
this from tony l who says nietzsche
predicted it
we killed god the ground of all being
and rationality
science couldn't survive once its
metaphysical foundation was removed
now that's a little heavy for a comment
at the top of the show but i think it's
absolutely true and it and it undergirds
a lot of what we're going to be talking
about
that why half of the country seems to
hate our country
at least at the level of the elites very
difficult
how do these guys get any sleep they
must be so just fired up all of the time
well when i want to sleep well do you
know what i turn to
you know i turn to my pillow when you
think my pillow you probably are
thinking of the greatest pillow that's
ever been invented fair enough it's got
pillow right in the name but my pillow
didn't just stop
at pillows my pillow created the new
giza dream bed sheets they look they
feel
great which means an even better night's
sleep for me which is crucial
to my very busy schedule of you know
smoking cigars and kind of blazing about
and playing with my little kid
my pillow found the world's best cotton
called geez it's ultra soft and
breathable it's also extremely durable
my pillow sheets come with a 60-day
money-back guarantee and a 10-year
warranty you're not going to need any of
that because you're going to love them
the first night you sleep on the giza
sheets you will never want to sleep on
anything else
giza dream sheets come in a variety of
sizes and colors
my pillow is making a special offer
right now but just
for you my dear listener you will
receive two for one
low price plus free shipping go to
mypillow.com and click on the radio
listeners square use promo code daily
wire
there you will find not only this
amazing offer but also deep discounts on
all the other my pillow products
including the my pillow mattress stopper
my pillow towel sets and so much more
call 1-800-951-7163
use promo code daily wire go to
mypillow.com make sure you use promo
code daily wire
corey bush not the only person tweeting
and declaring insane nonsense this
fourth of july there are a lot of people
doing that there was a twitter account
named lakota man i thought this was a
parody for a second
but i actually don't think it is i think
it might be might be serious
or at least earnest and sincere i'm not
serious this is not a serious person but
he might be earnest
the lakota man tweeted out hey america
fu for desecrating our sacred mountain
hashtag happy fourth and he's pointing
to
mount rushmore which i just got to visit
about a month or so ago
and it's very cool and it's very
beautiful and out in the middle of
nowhere
and this lakota man's very upset you see
because
the black hills are sacred to the lakota
people until the evil white man
and america came and stole it from them
give back the land now
this went viral a lot of people were
agreeing with this man's sentiment
his photo of him flipping off that mount
rushmore appears to have been
taken on a nokia phone from like 1992.
it was very weak
sort of uh graphics but i
googled it i said wait a second you know
because
i know it's fashionable these days to
believe that the evil white man
and america specifically is the only uh
group that ever conquered
and anyone else in history but of course
conquest is just
how states have developed throughout sin
since the dawn of time
so how long did the lakota have the
black hills for
and it turns out the lakota they did
they were not born
as a people in the black hills they did
not
spring up in the state of nature in the
black hills no they
conquered the cheyenne indians and
stole the black hills from them and you
know when they did it it wasn't
in prehistory it wasn't millennia ago or
wasn't
even all that many centuries ago it was
1776.
so as the americans were fighting for
their independence
the lakota were stealing the black hills
from the cheyenne
and now some random dude who calls
himself lakota man
is demanding that the united states give
the black hills back to
the lakota who stole it from why don't
we give it to the cheyenne you know
something tells me the cheyenne probably
stole it from somebody else as well and
it's not really
stealing so much as conquest that is how
america
developed through treaties first of all
let's not forget that in 1620 when the
pilgrims came to america
they initially established very strong
diplomatic relations
with the wampanoag indians and actually
allowed the wampanoag to become
a pretty serious political power in the
region that's why
the wampanoag partnered up with the
pilgrims against warring indian factions
and they had a mutually beneficial
relationship
because the indians contrary to modern
racial theories
were not just some passive sub-human
group they were men they were real men
who knew how to engage
in diplomacy and warfare with other men
and they did that for some time
until sadly the child of the the
wampanoag chieftain
uh stupidly declared war on the pilgrims
and then then it all went to uh hell in
a hand basket
a history for another time maybe when we
get to the anniversary of the
of the mayflower landing but why is it
that the united states is so is
singularly responsible for all these
terrible things
lakota man corey bush we're not the only
people criticizing the u.s
mia khalifa who is she's an adult film
actress i'm very
pleased to tell you by the way i don't
mean to uh preen or boast i'm obviously
a miserable sinner
who who you know has done terrible
things in my life just as has every
single person
but i can say with total honesty i have
never seen this woman's work
and i'm very glad because if her uh if
her professional work is anything like
her political commentary
i bet it's not very edifying mia khalifa
decided to take the occasion of the 4th
of july
to criticize and deride the united
states
morning happy 4th of july i just want to
remind you guys on this beautiful
independence day that all america does
is destabilize
other countries and then treat refugees
and immigrants from those destabilized
countries
like second-class citizens and trash so
a very silly commentary first of all
because we only have one legal system
of systemic racism in this country right
and that would be
affirmative action which prioritizes
non-white people it gives an advantage
to non-white people and
disadvantages white people and asians
also so the idea that refugees and
people from say the middle east or
africa are treated as second-class
citizens is just not as a fact of the
law they are treated much better
than whites and asians there is one
other
system of structural racism that gives
an advantage to some people
that would be our open borders so our
open borders
gives huge immigration priority to latin
americans
uh instead of other groups from around
the world again though
to non-white people so her argument here
completely ridiculous
but then let's take the first part
seriously she said all the united states
does is destabilize other nations
the united states has destabilized other
nations that's true
for instance when barack obama and
hillary clinton decided to
lead libya into a revolution that was
probably a bad idea
but they did that when when the united
states
under obama and clinton decided to
destabilize egypt by pulling their
support from our long-time ally mo
not muhammad gaddafi uh hosni mubarak
that was
probably a mistake so it's true the
united states has destabilized a lot of
parts of the world
destabilized iraq under saddam hussein
some people say that was a good thing to
do but
nevertheless certainly destabilizing
okay
is that first of all is the united
states the only country that does that
of course not
but second of all is that all the united
states does
see what what mia khalifa here is saying
that is
important for a discussion of political
philosophy and never thought i'd say
that statement
is the word all because
it's a matter of framing you remember
the 1619 project
made up a bunch of stuff right the
central thesis of the 1619 project at
the new york times is
that the american revolution was fought
to defend slavery it's just not true
it's completely fictitious
but whatever the times corrects that
seven months later
as i write in my book speechless what
the issue is is not the fact so much as
the framing the 1619 project
comes out and says we want to reframe
american history
to put slavery at the center of it and
so the lie here that mia khalif is
telling at least in that first sentence
is not that
the united states destabilizes countries
we have we've destabilized plenty of
countries as
have many other countries the lie is
that that's all that we do that's the
center
of the frame for for mia khalifa is that
the united states is this
force of evil that destabilizes
countries and then takes in refugees and
treats them poorly which is
obviously that part is not true but it's
that framing
that's what you've got to say what is
are we celebrating america are we not
celebrating america
is the fourth of july even our
independence day there's some debate
about that now because we have a second
national independence day the juneteenth
holiday
which you might call critical race
theory day i mean the juneteenth holiday
which was it was a local tradition in
galveston texas it became a national
holiday
because of these radical leftist race
hustlers that is
those were the people who were pushing
for it that was the argument that they
were giving
for the holiday on the floor of congress
and
it's in the very name now the national
independence day of juneteenth
uh on in the bill that that created this
new federal holiday
when they tell you that you've got to
believe them this is coming to a school
near you the national education
association this is the
nation's largest teachers union is
pushing for critical race theory
in all 50 states the nea president becky
pringle that can't be a real name
becky pringle says that we need to be
committed
uh and the teachers specifically need to
be committed
to uh make statements in the media quote
that support racial honesty in education
including but not limited to critical
race theory now this is a contradiction
she said
she said she wants to promote honesty
when it comes to
racial education and that includes
critical race through critical race
theory is dishonest
critical race theory is is not just
talking about slavery that's what
they're now trying to do
but uh but it's it's a specific
analytical lens that has its grounding
in
in a marxist understanding of the world
which i write about and speechless
notice here even beyond the effort to
put
crt in schools notice how they keep
shifting strategy
initially the left was defending
critical race theory then you remember
they
shifted to this theory of denying that
critical race theory
or the strategy rather of denying
critical race theory exists they said
what is critical race theory come on
now they're back to defending it and it
is terrible we got to fight it tooth and
nail
and when you want to fight these things
tooth and nail you need a good night's
sleep and that's why i strongly
recommend helix
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress
made for someone else why you're a
special person get a special mattress
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way that you sleep
they have several different mattress
models to choose from you got soft
medium firm mattresses
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers and the
mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free you
never got to go to that mattress store
again
just head out over to helix sleep.com
knowles take their two minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
10 year warranty and you can try it out
for 100 nights risk free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will love it look
people used to sleep on bales of hay
okay and then technology improved
well helix is just the latest stage of
that helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
don't sleep on a bale of hay don't sleep
on that old mattress technology
sleep on the best go to helix sleep.com
knowles for up to 200
off and two free pillows the fourth of
july
has become so controversial because
america has been
become so controversial that on the 4th
of july
national public radio npr
added a trigger warning to the
declaration of independence
the the thing that our taxpayers support
that is supposed to be our national
public radio added on our nation's
independence day
a trigger warning to warn people
about reading the founding document that
we are celebrating on independence
day the declaration of independence
editors note they write this document
contains a racist
slur against indigenous people
it's referring to this line everyone
knows we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they're endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
among these rights are the lights to
life liberty and pursuit of happiness
which is really misunderstood these days
and people who are trying to upend our
tradition of free speech
in america our tradition of education in
america are are misunderstanding what
that means
with regard to freedom of religion with
regard to freedom of speech we'll get
into that later because joe biden is
missing what that means
but everyone remembers that part you
know the declaration goes on and it
details specific issues that the
colonists have with king george
right they're not saying we're just
going to fight a revolution just to have
a good time we're going to fight a
revolution because because the king
insulted us once they're detailing
all of these insults that they believe
would justify even a revolution which
they're not taking lightly
and one of them is that the king has
quote
endeavored to bring on the inhabitants
of our frontiers
the merciless indian savages whose known
rule of warfare
is an undistinguished destruction of all
ages sexes and conditions
important to remember first of all
because the indians were
real people they weren't subhuman that
they did fight wars with the colonists
this was a real
problem and they did fight in ways that
were particularly brutal
our word cannibal comes from the carob
islanders
that's actually we didn't have a word
for cannibal before
them and the iroquois and upstate new
york practiced cannibalism and lots of
other things
scalping attacks on women and children
this was real this is not
the whitewashing of history and the
propaganda no the only propaganda you're
getting is the idea
that the native american indians were
living in harmony saying kumbayan drum
circles before the evil white man got
here it just wasn't true
there was vicious vicious barbaric
warfare going on
among the indian tribes and the
colonists had to deal with this
and one of the issues here is that king
george was not
helping out very much and this is a big
problem
now npr says you're not allowed to say
that well what if they were behaving
as merciless savages you know what the
word savage means it
derives from the woods it derives from
like forests
and these indian tribes were living in
the woods it's an actual a clinical term
all right enough of defending the
declaration of independence
what the npr is saying is even even if
that's true you're not allowed to say it
because that's offensive now
even if this was integral to our history
as a nation
we're not allowed to say that we're not
allowed to we've got exercise caution
when you're reading even the declaration
of independence
proving donald trump right once again
when he said they're not just coming
after robert e lee they're not just
coming after
stonewall jackson they're coming after
washington they're coming after
jefferson they're coming after the
declaration of independence the left is
coming after
the whole country and they're doing it
largely through the schools
they're doing it through all the
institutions but largely through the
schools they're trying to educate you
and indoctrinate you into hating your
country
enter david french i've always had a
perfectly fine relationship with david
french even though he's a
former republican he was considered a
conservative columnist
he might still consider himself a
conservative columnist but i think he's
now decidedly
in the liberal category but he
sort of gives cover to the liberal
regime and
very famously he he defended drag queen
story hours one of the blessings of
liberty in a debate with the
conservative so rob amari
so david french has an article in in the
new york times and i can't
it's not just david's article it's uh
camille foster
david french jason stanley and thomas
chatterton williams
this is uh four four people
writing one column i think they took
five words each how many people does it
take to write a column in the new york
times who knows
anti-critical race theory laws are
un-american
say the columnists
i won't read the whole thing because i
just i can't i can't we all had a nice
weekend and i can't
voice that upon us but it is important
to understand the argument they're
making they say what is the purpose of a
liberal education
this is the question at the heart of a
bitter debate that has been roiling the
nation for months
schools particularly at the kindergarten
to 12th grade level are responsible for
helping turn students into well-informed
and discerning citizens at their best
our nation's schools equip young minds
to grapple with complexity
and navigate our differences at their
worst they resemble indoctrination
factories pause it right there
education and indoctrination mean the
same thing they derive from the same
word they just have different
connotations education good
indoctrination bad but either way you're
teaching people stuff and
education is a coercive act and liberal
education
apparently these guys don't understand
that but liberal education even is a
coercive act because the point of
liberal education
is to make sense of your liberty and in
order to do that you need to
tamp down your basis appetites and you
need to cultivate your higher virtues
and you need to unlearn things that are
false and you need to
learn and practice things that are true
and you need to suppress
things that are vicious and you need to
cultivate things that are virtuous
this is a bit of a paradox it seems it
seems
tricky because we want to be free people
and we want
education to be liberating but in order
to cultivate our virtues we need to be
coerced
into that but if we're
but that coercion will then lead people
to be free and then to be able to think
about greater complexity so
you have to be forced to learn the two
plus two equals four
in order to have the freedom to
understand more complex mathematics you
have to be learn
you have to be forced rather to learn
the dates 1776 1620
1860 on and on and on
in order to have the freedom to think
about the higher comply and you and by
the way you have to be forced to learn
the ten commandments
you have to be forced to learn what they
mean you have to be forced to learn
things in ethics
and philosophy and religion in order to
then have the freedom to think
and to act at a higher level in all of
these things okay
so they make one crucial error already
they believe that a third grade
classroom is a free marketplace of ideas
it's not
it it is an indoctrination factory it
has to be
because you because students have to
learn one thing and when you learn
a thing it excludes other things because
the truth is arrogant so
there's that first little slight of hand
there get this out of your mind a
third-rate classroom is not a free
marketplace of ideas
they say these initiatives that are
going around are marketed as
anti-critical race theory laws
we the authors of this essay have wide
ideological divergences
on the explicit targets of this
education they say by the way
that uh the people who wrote this column
one's a conservative one's a libertarian
one's a
moderate one's a liberal one's this
one's that i don't see a single
conservative here
i don't who is the conservative
none of these people as far as i can
tell is a conservative
but they go on and they say that this is
why in the name of freedom in the name
of free marketplace of ideas in the name
of academic freedom we need to
we need to teach crt in schools
as you may have known i just wrote a
book that is making the exact
opposite case from what this very stupid
new york times column is making
i highly recommend you read the book i
thank everybody who has read the book
you know the book
just on i think it was on friday after
we were off air the book hit number one
on all of amazon there was a little bit
of a
controversy last week because our book
outsold every other nonfiction book in
the country
by the way no bulk sales no cheating
this was all
just people going out and buying books
and the new york times snubbed us even
though we had something like 40
higher sales than the number one on
their list that week and we had many
multiples of the sales that were lower
on that list it's fine who cares about
the new york times
uh people went out and bought it then on
friday it became the number one book in
the country
we beat quentin tarantino his new book
at once upon a time in hollywood which
is this novel he had released last week
you know from the movie we were beating
that now you know we're still toward the
top of the list but it you know we're
it's not number one as of right now
until you all go out and buy that book
uh this is very important because this
debate is going
to define the right into the future and
i think it's going to define whether we
want to win or we want to lose
you have people who i think are pretty
dishonest
and at the very least terribly terri
terribly naive
but i think it's a little worse than
that even they are
making the argument that if
conservatives ever assert our political
right if parents
ever for instance have a say about the
curriculum if we ever observe that
curricula are necessarily exclusive if
you teach one thing you're not going to
teach the other thing there's only so
many weeks in the semester
only so many books you can read that if
we if we just acknowledge those basic
truths then we're somehow unamerican and
you know there's nothing more american
than ibrahim kendy and robin deangelo
and tearing down statues of george
washington
it's false it's a lie there are court
jester conservatives
who are upholding the liberal regime and
pretending to to try to conserve
something they're not
you've got to i mean this this may be
the dumbest new york times column
i have read in months which is really
really saying something
so if you want the antidote to that
column you can you can check out the
book and thanks for those of you who've
already done it
not everyone hates america we'll get
into george foreman just a second first
though
in a time when the prevailing narrative
is an oppressive
and evil america the daily wire is here
to remind you
that your long weekend of independence
day celebrations was made possible by
the legends who sacrificed their own
lives for the future of america that is
why we started a new podcast called
america's forgotten heroes which boasts
seven episodes detailing the lives of
seven brave men
subscribe now to america's forgotten
heroes on apple podcast spotify or
anywhere
you might listen because the sixth
episode is out today tuesday
july 6th and the last action-packed
episode drops tomorrow
july 7th for a total of seven episodes
too many heroes never receive the
recognition they deserve
sharing their stories with you this
independence day holiday was our small
tribute
to their heroism if you like what you
hear leave a five-star review please and
help share these incredible stories
thank you for listening
thank you to the heroes that made this
terrific podcast i really really like
this podcast
uh who made it possible we will be right
back with a lot more
not everyone hates america a lot of
people hate america
cory bush the democrat congressman seems
to hate america
uh the silly people who wrote in the new
york times
defending critical race theory they
don't seem they don't definitely don't
get american i i wonder i wonder what
what kind of vision of america they
really want to have going into the
future
mia khalifa a the the adult film store
she doesn't like america i mean this is
everywhere this is the whole culturalist
so much of the politics you know who
loves america
george foreman the master of grilling
the olympic gold medalist the
heavyweight
champion boxer george
foreman still loves america he tweeted
out quote
for about 54 years people have asked me
not to keep saying i love america well i
do and i'm not ashamed
don't leave it love it happy fourth of
july
i really like that this is still
really powerful stuff you know i know
people are feeling a little down in the
dumps about america right now because
so many of our liberties are being taken
away our traditions are being upended
our standards
have been upended by the radicals for
the past 50 years or so and we've been
impotent on the right at fighting back
because we we've misunderstood what it
is
because we read stupid columns in the
new york times like the one that defends
critical race theory
but george foreman says now hold on i
still love america and
it does remind me that when when you see
an american flag
generally speaking you're looking at a
conservative right it didn't used to be
that way both sides used to wave the
american flag
that is no longer true and actually
there were some journalists who were
reporting on that
this week you know how much i hate to
say i told you so on this show
well i've been saying it for a while i
said the american flag has become a
partisan symbol
because the left hates america so they
hate the symbol of america so they
protest the symbol of america
and everyone told me no that's crazy
you're misinterpreting it it's wrong
they just
people are protesting police brutality
or whatever that's why they're
protesting the flag which is the symbol
of the whole country
but i said no they just they don't like
america they want to upend america so
they have their own flags they'll wave
the
the rainbow flag they have a new it's
like a new new
racial rainbow transgender flag it's
called the progress flag
that's the fly that's the flag of the
liberal empire or the or the blm flag
they'll wave that but they're very
unlikely
to wave the american flag well george
foreman still waves the american flag i
still wave the american flag
american patriots i think still wave
that flag there were some customers at
walmart just spontaneously
over the weekend broke out into song
singing our national anthem
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
usa you gotta say it's a it's a really
beautiful scene people were tweeting
this around
a lot of leftists and saying uh what a
weird country this is how strange how no
it's weird
it's weird for you because you are a
selfish narcissist
if you if you find that weird
that says more about you than it does
about the country
and about the people who are singing
that
it is natural and right to love your
country as an extension of filial piety
as the love that you have for your
family a lot of people don't love their
families very much though either
or respect their families they
get rid of all of that for the cult of
the individual people on the right do
this as well it's much
much more common on the left but people
on the right have done this as well
both the left and the right have really
made an idol out of the individual
and maximizing individual autonomy the
left has done it in the realm of sex
basically and so the social realm and
the right has done it in the realm of
economics and
business for instance but both are true
and
uh you know there is something to having
a country where you have to
care about your countrymen you have to
care about history you have to care
about posterity you have to sacrifice a
little bit it's not all about you
and those people in that walmart who
come in all shapes and sizes
multi-racial
right there because there's no lens
where the left can say
see it's really it's just white people
it's just men or it's just this or it's
no
the difference is those people love
their country
and they're just ordinary walmart
shoppers
and members of congress cannot even be
bothered to show a little respect for
their country
wealthy pornographers cannot be bothered
to show respect people who are very
very flamboyantly selfish can and
look we all we all have a temptation
toward pride and selfishness you've got
to tamp that down and
and our nation's birthday is a good day
to do that to remember
what you love about the country
zuckerberg proved it by the way so
there was this very strange video of
zuckerberg going around the internet
where he was
it's like hoverboarding on a lake waving
an american flag
and it looked i mean he just he must
have just woken up one day and he was
like
what do what do americans do siri what
do americans do okay yes
i will wave a flag and
i mean it looked great it was an amazing
video he still didn't quite look human
but it was a very cool video of him
doing this hoverboard thing
he got some great nice background music
to it little john denver
there is a political lesson to learn
from this mark zuckerberg is a very very
intelligent person
i don't know about his views on the
country i hope he likes the country
but i don't know i'm not venturing i
guess one way or the other but what i do
know is that mark zuckerberg thinks
it is good for him to be seen waving the
red white and blue
that that symbol still has power that
despite
what the antifa people and the blm
people and the leftist people
despite their ceaseless attacks
on the star-spangled banner that
symbol still stirs the heart
it still it still makes people think
about what is good and right and true
and just and beautiful
and we should not surrender that symbol
we should not we should not abandon that
still
still powerful matthew mcconaughey
actually had some some pretty good
thoughts on this whole thing i can't
believe i would say because matthew
mcconaughey has said some things
recently politically that we're just a
little strange
he appears to be wanting to angle to run
for office at some point he's got this
new book out
green lights which by the way speechless
was was a little higher on the charts
and green lights
for the past few days i don't know now
where it is maybe maybe we've fallen
behind again but
you know i've heard people are enjoying
that book mcconaughey obviously has
political ambitions and
he had a really important point on how
to
think about what's going on the the
riots in the streets burning down the
country the
vitriol that's largely almost
exclusively coming from the left
the politicization of every institution
that the feeling that conservatives have
lost so much power
now we're even we're arguing over
washington and lincoln and jefferson in
the
star-spangled banner mcconaughey says
the country is just going through
puberty happy birthday america
yes indeed as we celebrate our
independence
today as we celebrate our birth as a
nation a day that kick-started
a revolution to gain our sovereignty
let's admit that this last year's trip
around the sun was also
another head scratcher um but let's also
remember that
we are babies you know as a country
we're basically going through puberty in
comparison to um
other countries timelines um and we're
going to go through growing pains we are
going through growing pains this is not
an excuse to say this is just a reality
and this is good because we got to keep
learning
we got to keep maturing we got to keep
striving we got to keep climbing we got
to
keep building and we got to make sure we
maintain
hope along the way as we continue to
evolve why because it's who we are
why because the alternative sucks
okay so then he goes on and it's kind of
just platitudinous nonsense about
progress and evolve man you know right
all right all right but the first part
is actually
is actually really smart mcconaughey is
saying
this is a young country and we're going
through puberty and that is
certainly true and conservatives
sometimes get a little nostalgic
okay and we cling to the past as my
friend father george rutler says
nostalgia is history after a few drinks
and as my dead friend
i think we would have been friends had i
met him i hope i meet him someday
chesterton famously says
when you when you leave a white
fence just you leave it you leave it out
in the middle of nowhere you go away
when you come back it will not be a
white fence any longer
there will be dirt there will be bugs
there will be stuff all over it because
you don't leave it in stasis
you leave it in a torrent of change the
thing that is
is constant is change there is no such
thing as stasis
in this world and so when we pine for
this time
of 1776 we're pining for something that
we can never go back to none of us would
actually want to go back then no one
actually wants to live outside of his
own time
because our time has in some ways shaped
us and so we are suited
for the time that we are in uniquely
suited for this time that we're in
and we need to do something with that we
are very very young
as a country 250 years old just about
so so what is our narrative going to be
the narrative is is not
was not settled 20 years ago 50 years
ago 60 years ago 100 years ago it is
still settling now
and the left understands this the left
understands the power of narrative so
they are trying to shape
what the narrative of our country is in
order to destroy the country they're
trying to say the country is essentially
evil
and everyone who made it is evil so
we've got to just knock down their
statues and clear it away so we can
refound a country along our lines
we obviously have to push back against
that but we need to offer a different
narrative
and it's not just going to say keep the
statues up yeah we want to keep the
statues up but what are we offering what
is our substantive vision
it's the point i've i've hammered home
for some time now
it's not enough just to argue about
procedure it's not enough just to argue
about form and to say for instance i
defend free speech in the abstract no
you've got to have something to say
you've got to recognize there will be
standards there will there will be a
narrative there will be taboos
what are they going to be what do we
think is good
are we willing to promote what we think
is good are we willing to suppress what
we think is bad
we have to that's how culture works it's
inevitable but we we
so far have not really had the courage
to do it over the past 15 20 years
and if you read dumb columns like this
crt one
in the new york times then then you're
not going to have the courage to do it
ever
are we really willing to say this is
true and suppress things that are false
i hope so i think that's the only way
that we're ever going to be able to
to fight back at all i mean we've we've
uniformly
ceaselessly lost over the past 20 years
that the left for
duped us into into falling for their
trap and they're setting the narrative
we need to set the narrative look what's
going on there's a
report from entertainment insider right
now there is a campaign
to cram a lot of lgbt
transgender radical sexual ideology
into children's programming this is not
just an organic movement you know we've
covered it uh the
bizarre drag queens on nickelodeon and
all this kind of crazy stuff
we've been covering it but it's not just
organic it's not just happening
by accident entertainment insider points
out
there is an overt campaign to instill
queer themes and elements of lgbtq
culture into these shows
there are according to the insider
259 lgbtq characters
in mainstream children's programming
today
that's weird i'm not saying you can't
have like a gay character or something
i'm
i'm pointing out it's very strange how
disproportionate the representation is
here
there are how many how many characters
are there in kids shows i don't think
there are that many
how are there hundreds and hundreds of
characters who are
going along with transgenderism that's
just weird that doesn't that doesn't
reflect reality which is
the argument that very often you'll hear
people who are promoting
radical sex ideology in schools or
critical race theory in schools they'll
say well we just want to
expose children to reality and show them
you know but that's this isn't reality
what are you talking about drag queen
story hour isn't reality
there this is a very strange niche
sexual fetish that some people have
why are you now presenting this in as
many public libraries and schools as you
possibly can why are you putting this
all over children's programming critical
race theory isn't reality critical race
theory denies reality for goodness sakes
why are you putting that in schools
because you're trying to
transform reality you're trying to
redefine
reality this has been the campaign of
the left for a very very long time
this is uh in part using glaad
glad is one of the lgbt organizations in
the country
uh by the way not even the most radical
the most radical i think goes to the
human rights campaign
ridiculously named human rights campaign
they're the ones that really
successfully redefine marriage
but but you have for instance one uh
showbiz type who's his name is petoskey
who says
i had to fight with the help of glad to
get the actual word pride in
a script instead of it being called
rainbow parade or something like that he
had to fight he'd go in
in writers rooms there are these people
who are campaigning to get this ideology
in there they're campaigning to get this
ideology
into schools we need to fight back there
is there is nothing
american about permitting radicals to
upend the whole culture
conservatives used to know this william
f buckley jr launched his career on a
book
talking about how insane it is to allow
radicals to do this sort of thing in
schools
now we've forgotten that because of the
squishes and the courchester
conservatives who are who have
outrageously claimed the mantle of
conservatism to undermine that tradition
is that america no if that's america
then something's gone seriously wrong we
need to
reclaim an older tradition a lot of
people don't know what america is joe
biden
just made this statement joe biden came
out he said it's impossible to define
what america is i've often said
that america is the only nation in the
world
founded on an idea
every other nation in the world is
founded on base of either
that that your geography or
or ethnicity or religion
you can define every almost everyone
else based on those
characteristics but you can't define
america
i defy you to tell me what constitutes
an american
you can't do it we're an incredibly
diverse democracy
but there's one thing that does define
us as a country
we're founded on an idea that we hold
these truths to be self-evident
but all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator with certain
inalienable rights
pause it right there did you catch the
contradiction
i bet a lot of people didn't catch the i
mean you you the listener i'm sure did
but a lot of people listening to joe
biden's
droning half asleep speech probably did
not he said
you can't define americans by their
religion
you can't you can't you can't i defy you
to define an american by his religion
no it's defined by an idea that all men
are created equal and
endowed by their creator with certain
unalienable rights uh
hold on sounds kind of religious to me
you know what is what are religions
religions have ideas they make certain
claims
about history perhaps about the the
world about ideas about
what what this whole world is who we are
in relation to the world
america first of all america is not just
an idea america has a creedal aspect to
her character but it's not just an idea
it's also geography it's also
specific people it's also like things
that have happened
you know it's also the sea to shining
sea and the great plains and
all these things but there is a creedal
aspect to a character
and that creedal aspect is a religious
idea that
by definition excludes other ideas
if our country is founded on the idea
that
all men are created equal and endowed by
our creator with certain unalienable
rights
then america excludes atheism it
excludes it it's not part of the
american idea
if you are a militant
die-hard atheist we need to get religion
out of all
aspects of public life you are
anti-american
i'm sorry to tell you that if you are
one i'm not saying if you're one of
these amiable
sort of agnostic types who just says
whatever i don't really i'm saying if
you are
knocked down the ten commandments at the
courthouse's kind of atheist you're
anti-american
according to joe biden's own logic
because america was founded on an idea
right and the idea
is a religious idea that god endowed us
with rights
so that yeah i can i can at least define
an american in that way
what is an american i did not not bound
by race well that's true i mean there
were you know you can trace
racial groups in the country it was
settled by englishmen right that's just
a fact of
history america was settled by
englishmen
then you know some irish came in then
some you know you'd say there were
obviously
african slaves brought over but they
were not considered citizens for quite a
long time
uh there was bloody civil war to resolve
that problem and then
you had some some waves of migration
and then you tamped down on migration we
had effectively closed borders for a
long time
so yeah you can you can kind of trace
these things well what binds us together
then
one that religious idea how about
language we do increasingly we speak
other languages in this country
but we speak english right it's all our
documents are written in english all our
founding documents are written in
english
we speak english on the street so that
binds us together if you don't speak
english
better learn it because america speaks
english
for now and we should we're going to
speak one language or another
words are necessarily exclusive and
discriminatory they discern one thing
from another
so you better learn it and if you can't
speak english
you are putting yourself outside of the
american tradition
it there freedom requires
limits as i have said many many times
now joe biden doesn't understand that
he's just given us his two cents he's
actually given us
his 16 cents the biden administration
actually
bragged i'm not joking actually bragged
that the cost of a fourth of july
cookout is down this year i said because
thanks to the policies of joe biden
the cost of a fourth of july cookout is
down
you know how much 16 cents
they put this the white house social
media accounts
put out a graphic that said the cost of
a fourth of july cookout in 2021 is down
16 cents from last year gas is through
the roof by the way so you can
but even if it were even if even if you
actually have what
is that to brag about that's the best
they could come up with
because the country is doing much much
worse under joe biden
that's it and it's not even just the
money by the way you know
obviously i want our economy to thrive i
want people to to be able to be doing
well and support their families
but there's more to it and this is a
mistake the right has made by by
focusing exclusively on economic matters
and
plugging gdp up you know for
for any and all excuses to do that with
without any question about the wisdom of
that whether we ship
jobs overseas whether we completely open
up the border it's totally fine there
are cultural issues here that matter too
even when the the cultural conservatives
say politics is downstream of culture
well okay then
there's more to life than 16 cents i
think
i think that's there's more the question
is who are we as a country
a country is going to be defined not by
its expansiveness
but by its limits no matter how
expansive the country is
no matter how broad-minded the country
is whether it's very narrow-minded very
broad-minded the thing that will define
it will be the limits
a nation is defined by its borders a
culture is defined
by the borders of what it believes what
it
thinks about itself what it says this is
why speech
is so fundamental i think this is why
the book hit number one on amazon
why my book speechless controlling words
controlling mindset number one it's
because
it's not just i think the book is really
terrific but i think it's because we
know that this issue is
is what's at stake here this issue is
going to define
the country what is it that we
say what is it that we believe what is
it that we're celebrating
on the 4th of july for those of us who
celebrate it i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show i'll see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show prominent leftists in
politics media and culture protest
america on independence day plus
the national education association
pushes critical race theory that's today
on the benchmark show give it a listen